hallo und willkommen zurück zu einer
neuen episode von the german bayern bis
heute lockt mann aus indonesien hey
hallo du bist ein langjähriger easy
german zuschauer kann man das sagen das
stimmt was ist denn deine lieblings
episode einkaufen apps alle sechs
einkaufen diese episode ist schon
ziemlich alt und lud man hat uns sehr
beeindruckt eben weil er die episode
fast komplett auswendig kann und weil er
das kann und weil das mein lieblings
episode ist haben wir gedacht wir gehen
heute mal mit ihm einkaufen und wo kann
man das sonntags in berlin nicht in den
geschäften in diesem sonntags
geschlossen in deutschland aber auf dem
mauerpark flohmarkt der mauerpark ist
bekannt in berlin früher stand hier die
mauer jetzt ist hier jeden sonntag
flohmarkt und wir wollen was fragen wir
die leute einkaufen was machen sie heute
kaufen oder was haben sie heute gekauft
ob man dann will ich sagen hier ist ein
mikrofon gehen wir mal los oder was geht
man wäre das was für dich
sehr gut der wahl vor denn schlechte
winter in berlin und schöner alter pelz
sowas kauft man hier auf dem flohmarkt
vintage möbel und klamotten
was suchen sie noch einfach so generell
also mir macht es einfach spaß einfach
da durchzugehen
kommen sie aus berlin ja ich wohne in
berlin ja seit 23 jahren 23 jahre also
hier geboren und aufgewachsen ich bin in
afghanistan geboren und dort
aufgewachsen und dann bin ich mit 20
nach deutschland gekommen und wir
gefährden sie werden sehr gut
ja und zwar wollen wir gerne wissen was
ihr heute schon eingekauft hat
ein schal ja hast du schon zu zeigen
dessen schwarz das ist glaube ich nicht
so interessant habt ihr schon was
gekauft heute noch nicht was kauft ihr
noch ich weiß es noch nicht sie
kaufrecht ein hemd aber ich weiß es
nicht
wir haben sie aus berlin ja gehst du
öfters hier hin
ja wenn ich jetzt noch gar nicht also
wir sind gekommen und gewalten uns
wahrscheinlich smog auf dem schmuck ja
welche antwort nicht mobile vielleicht
abend ein jahr später nach essen und was
ist dein lieblingsessen
auf mauerpark gibt so dass rucola und
käse tomaten sind da drin da so typisch
deutsch
ich möchte es nicht ich weiß gar nicht
was ich guck mal das ist so ein
typischer hipster stand hit star kennt
selbst daher werde hier kannst du zahlst
heimat als alte einkaufen einmachgläser
vintage möbel du siehst und kisten
kisten auch ganz populäre berliner schau
mal da ja nicht unsere berliner
wohnungen wohl nur es gibt dann nur
einen holzfußboden und einen stuhl oder
eine kiste oder so das ist eine typische
berliner hipster wohnung so ein riesen
zimmer und dann ein eimer
früher war das schrott heute ist es
kunst theater
ich suche eine kleine runde pils lampe
weil ich mag pilze wir wären ihr garten
stoff folge kaufte und jetzt reichlich
wie lang arbeiteten hier schon hier auf
mauerpark 89 jahre alt mittlerweile ja
jeden sonntag bist du hier jeden sonntag
ist das so ein typischer hipster stand
hier keine ahnung er so leicht sein aber
ich glaube das ist auch eher mäßig hast
du schon was gekauft hatte wills
hinauskamen
vielleicht wenn ich als gutes finish
testet sessel frage beantworten deutsch
sprachkurs und ihr könnt jetzt menschen
beim deutsch lernen helfen was habt ihr
heute eingekauft eingekauft hat was
würdet ihr gern kaufen
ich hätte gern schal ganz bescheiden und
was ist das coolste daran jetzt arbeiten
die kollegen das essen wird die stimmung
durch schon schön her wenn es dir alle
leute so ziehen nicht nur auf diesem
markt also irgendwann kannst du sie alle
ihr seid so eine richtige community für
familien mafia ja was haben sie heute
kommt gar nichts bis jetzt
lassen sie doch man möchte nichts erst
mal gucken wir wollen gucken nur zeit
vertreiben
was suchst dir denn heute wir sind mit
unseren französischen austauschschülern
hier wissen eigentlich gar nichts also
ihr zeigt den typisch berlin genauso
richtige tue die sachen sind ja
eigentlich mehr touristen oder mehr
berliner eindeutig touristen superstar
wer seine band spielen die musik meine
motivation ist einfach ja musik zu
machen spaß zu haben und spaß auch mit
anderen zu teilen denn den spaß den
angeblich wieder zurück und dann kann
man wieder mehr spaß geben und zurück
geben uns ein schöner kreislauf ich habe
bis heute noch gar nichts gekauft wir
sind gerade erst angekommen
aber was wollen sie möchten sich eine
hose kaufen meine frau und ich habe mir
gedacht ich kauf mir vielleicht ein
super nintendo wovon sie auch nichts
weiß nichts bestimmtes irgendwelche
geschenke
habt ihr schon mal was größeres gekauft
ich habe mir meine lampe gekauft
so ein marokkanisch für die euch zu
verschönern ja und den rucksack habe ich
auch gekauft aber tue ich langsam kaputt
gehandelt von wo nach wo 95 auf 70
glaube ich ja das war es mit der episode
stuckmann hat dir gefallen mir gefällt
ist super was hast du eigentlich was
gekauft leider ihr habt noch nichts
gekauft aber ja noch hat irgendwas
gekauft einen kamera tasche sonderlich
sie ist wirkt wie haben statt eine sich
eine neue kameratasche gekauft ja ja und
wenn ihr mal in berlin einen flohmarkt
sehen möchte dann ist das hier zunächst
ein großer und bekannter flohmarkt der
mauerpark flohmarkt am mauerpark in
prenzlauer berg im norden von berlin
schaut mal vorbei und wir bedanken uns
jetzt nochmal fürs zuschauen bei euch
und sagen auf wiedersehen und wollen
euch daran erinnern dass ihr unseren
kanal abonniert wenn ihr mehr sehen
wollt und dass wir uns auch gerne
unterstützen könnt denn wir finanzieren
dieses projekt dank eurer spenden und
ihr könnt mitglied bei uns werden in
unserer petrin community den links seht
ihr hier unten
und wenn ihr das macht kriegt ihr von
uns auch tolle extras wie zum beispiel
outtakes aus der heutigen episode danke
luttmann dass du dabei warst und bis
bald
auf wiedersehen in indonesien
wiedersehen in der nähe